do you think that you've been doing less
or more like
exercising since since the pandemic
started because i feel like
it's either one or the other people like
well there's one people there's
the people that pick up running and now
they're running marathons and [ __ ] like
that and there's people that pick up
drinking
i mean i don't think i haven't been
drinking that much because i got i got
i came down with some really bad acid
reflux so i just like my man
dude yeah wait you got gerd you got
you got the gerd homie let's go wait yo
i have these
i have these pills hold up where are
they see cody's cody thinks i'm lying
every time i say i got acid reflux and
now it's real
it's the [ __ ] i don't think you're
lying yeah
if you if you eat it like um it's like
okay well that's french uh amid relief
enzymes
okay if you eat something spicy dude
take one of these or two of these right
before
you like don't bloat if you send me a
pic bro so i can live my life again
dude this shit's amazing this this one's
really helped and then i started
supplementing turmeric and uh uh
fish oils with omega-3s and vitamin d's
and
i've been doing a lot better but i i was
also on the like the chemical pill that
like
didn't really do too much but we got it
we got to do another group
rappers with gerd yo gerd boys gerd boys
so we got for profit then gerd boys
we're already dude we're gonna build the
first
like like label where all the artists
like all the acts are just four people
mixed around you you know what i'm
saying
like we'll be all the acts like the same
four same four people so it's like
oh yeah there's guard boys i like but
then there's four
prizes like g or g-e-r-d like i said
dude that's hilarious we can also
only be dressed up as like intestines
uh okay and then no one can see who we
really are
and then everyone's like dude have you
heard the new gerd song yeah that's just
so refluxy dude and
we get on stage and you cannot see us at
all
and all the vocals are like sound like
they're [ __ ] like just wet and like
like like it's not even like rapping
he said you go you got to hear this [ __ ]
right here
[Music]
oh man my guy's spinning over there then
yeah we can i can't i can't get over the
fact that you just said reflect
reflection
[Laughter]
or uh dude i'm gagging to this right
producer
the producer is just phlegm yeah
yeah this is our manager butt mud um
just shows up man so dude did you have
any gerd making the album
were you sensitive to gerd yeah
really sensitive to gerd dude no i mean
like is that actually the thing like
i have that like whether we do the
podcast or some other [ __ ] i go all
right i can't eat like these kinds of
foods because my voice is gonna like get
[ __ ] up like do you ever have that or
no
i mean until i like don't know
if i had kovid to be completely honest
but i think i may have
and then like i just do i just like
developed gerd out of nowhere weird
like damn i'm i'm always like a relative
i'm like relatively anxious i'm sure
you're anxious right like your anxieties
and you know we all do
um but like i don't know you know if
that would be the whole sole reason
because like i got sick in australia
when i lost my voice also and then i
just like
developed acid reflux and i didn't know
it was really acid reflux for like
x amount of time yeah you know i really
cut out
uh coffee do you drink coffee still no
i'm off
yeah i i'm i like i was really doing
really decent for like five or six days
then i had a coffee and then
just immediately i was just like okay
well that's definitely not something i
should be doing
so
[Music]
hell yeah what what month were you in
australia that you got sick
it was like end of january like very
early february
this is like right when everything was
starting to pop off
and uh i i remember flying like
15 times in like two weeks three weeks
oh that's brutal man and i yeah i didn't
i didn't have a mask people weren't like
really
worried about it i you know i wasn't
like did you have a fever
like were the symptoms similar to coven
i remember like sweating for because i
had this i had the same [ __ ]
like like drenched like my bed was wet
type [ __ ]
um damn i had a sore throat
my like tonsils like swole got really
swollen
i had a headache um i didn't really have
a cough i think the cough was
you know from my throat and everything
else
um i didn't have like i wasn't like
puking
or i wasn't like shooting a bunch i
don't know like it could have been
every like everybody has different
symptoms right some people
maybe even asymptomatic i you never know
like
yeah you know anybody who's gotten it we
think
we think cody had it really i mean
he just felt like ass after he came like
the very beginning
this is yes it was hard to say
that's true yeah but we were but but
like it was it was crazy it was like
every time we left the city
we look on the news the next day and it
would be like
like first case is detected in this city
and so we're in these places where it's
following us basically and every single
night we're like
meeting with people for the meet and
greet right like a lot of people
so we're standing right right beside
them whatever and i got sick like the
night before we left we did
we did the show but i had like a really
bad fever and i flew back on the plane
like like still sort like the fever had
sort of broken at that point
but then i had a cough and then whatever
and then i got over it and i was totally
fine but
you didn't have anything or anything
because tests weren't weren't a thing
yeah like no one knew what the [ __ ] it
was
but you don't have any like long lasting
effects of it or or
you don't think no i just can't smell or
taste anything
but other than that totally never really
he's [ __ ] around oh i was like dude
your life sucks ass now
i would really get the best of you yeah
nothing really happened my [ __ ] dick
got so much bigger but other than that
dude imagine messing with legit the only
thing it did
it only affected males and just made
your dick
huge just [ __ ] throbbing dude
dudes running into [ __ ] saddle
ranches like spit in my face spinning my
face
drinking everybody's drink
dude's just licking pedestrians
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait yo we were gonna make a song called
wait remember that song
um yeah wait
did that okay you ever sent it to you no
no no but i mean i don't
it's it's really dumb it's literally
just like wait
wait wait wait wait it's
it's [ __ ] awesome it's y2k made the
beat
i still have the project file actually i
have it on my on this computer right
just play it dude
yeah smash it let the fans hear it bro i
haven't heard it in
ages man give them the snippets welcome
to the
i can do it like oh you have to like be
a full
10 tech supporters trying to figure out
how to route the audio through the
[ __ ] zoom
play played in the bonus we could figure
out how to play it i will play it in the
bonus
oh and oh dude yeah so my audio is still
so messed up dude anytime i say anything
you guys are like
yeah totally
you're like literally living a time zone
behind us it's wild
you